I know for a fact that you're tired of
searching the internet for the best ways
to make money online. Every day,
thousands of internet gurus tell you to
try affiliate marketing or drop
shipping, and they're all full of
Those things don't work in 2026,
especially not in the new era of AI. In
my AI venture studio, Martell Ventures,
I've created dozens of companies that
now generate millions, and I can tell
you there's only a few real ways to make
money online. To make it simple, we're
breaking everything into four buckets.
Trash, the stuff you shoulding run away
from. Easy, businesses you can launch in
under three months, earning 5 to 10K a
month. Medium, skills that can be
profitable within a year, making 10 to
50K a month. And hard, long-term plays
that may take more time, but can make
you millions if done right. I'll tell
you the income potential, difficulty,
how long it'll take to make money, and
who is best for each bucket. So, without
further explanation, let's get into the
real ways to make money in 2026. [music]
Starting with bucket number one, the
trash bucket. The income potential for
this bucket is zero or even worse, could
be negative. Difficulty, I mean, it
looks easy, but it gives you nothing
back. time frame wastes months [music]
before you realize it was dead on
arrival. Who is it best for? No one. NFT
flipping. The hype is freaking done.
Look at all the projects that launched.
Nobody made money. The ones that thought
they made money have lost money. And if
you're going to start there and you
haven't made money ever online, that's a
losing recipe. Next, crypto trading
moves really fast. Most people don't
have the patience and it's [music]
without any crazy skill. Unless you're
the person that tries to frontr run the
whole freaking trade, most people lose
money every freaking day. Next,
multi-level marketing. If the way you
make money is getting paid to recruit
people to join your thing and you don't
shape the business and you don't
actually sell anything and you actually
spend more money to buy product to try
to get up the leaderboard, that's not a
business you want to be in. Most of
these are scams. Next, basic caption or
subtitles. [music] Now, AI does it
faster, cheaper, and way better. After
that, we have low-level data entry. This
is wild to watch that people still think
they're going to make money on this
because AI tools have replaced this work
completely. Fiverr Microtask, my
favorite website on the internet 5 years
ago. Trying to make money this way. It's
not the worst on the list, but it has
zero long-term growth. Next, we got
print ondemand. Here's the thing, it's
really crowded and everyone sells the
same stuff. And last but not least, my
favorite, day trading. Here's the deal.
If you're not completely into it,
obsessed on it, and just want to just
live the day trading life, it is way
easier to lose money than to make any.
Basically, all these are like trying to
race across the ocean in a car. [music]
You keep drowning because you need a
different vehicle. So, to make sure your
idea isn't in this bucket, I need you to
run your idea through the trash filter.
Three simple questions. One, is AI
already replacing this? Two, is the
industry shrinking or going obsolete?
Three, is it easier to lose money than
to make money? If you answer yes to any,
move on immediately. Now, let's talk
about the first bucket that actually
pays real money. Bucket number two, easy
bucket. The income potential, 5 to 10k a
month, no problem. The difficulty, low,
simple skills, fast turnaround. Time
frame, 30 to 60 days to actually get
paid. And it's best for beginners trying
to gain some momentum and build some
skills. You don't need a degree for
these. These just need basic execution
and learning how to talk to customers.
Just get your first dollar online. Build
some confidence and learn how clients
work. Here are some examples. The first
one, basic short form editing. If you
haven't seen all the people that have
like these clipping accounts and people
like edit these short form videos all
over social media, I mean, the demand is
[music] huge. Every person now seems to
be a content creator and AI makes it
incredibly easy. So, it's easy to get
paid fast. Love this one. [music] Next,
we got social media copywriting. Every
business in the world needs to learn how
to use words to get customers to buy and
they need somebody to help them. And the
tools are getting so good. Just get the
client, do the work, get paid. Next,
we've got the AI chatbot setup for small
businesses. I love this one because
every small business needs more time
back. And if you can be the person that
comes in and help them set this up, they
will pay you money because it's easy for
them to redeploy their time to make more
money than what they paid you. use this
one. Next, we've got the AI
receptionist. Along those same lines,
it's crazy today when you can use tools
like your.com that you can get paid to
set up for small businesses to take all
the inbound calls to qualify, [music]
sell, fill up schedules, answer
questions, and it'll do it without being
upset, complain, take time off, or call
in sick. Helping businesses do this is a
great way to make money. Next, we've got
UGC content. Brands want to pay for real
people showing their products, not
professional models. Helping a brand
connect with a creator and you're the
middleman and you get a piece of this.
My buddy in Dubai, this is his whole
business and they're already doing 100K
[music] a month. So, you can make 5 to
10 starting with this one. And last, the
virtual or executive assistant. It's one
of my fave categories cuz I wrote a book
called Buy Back Your Time. See, rich
people hate wasting time and they'll pay
you to get it back. The best part is you
get paid to hang out with smart people
that can teach you about life to help
them get done. Nob brainer. A great
example of this bucket is my buddy Mark.
No background, no experience. He decides
to start approaching companies to help
them take long form content that they
were creating using AI to break it down
into short form clips. And that simple
process of using AI tools, making it
repeatable, and turning around really
quick has scaled now. Whereas a
freelancer, he earns $30,000 a month
with only seven clients. This bucket is
about learning how to master a high
income skill. Because if you already
knew how to make millions, you'd be
making millions. Which means you're
going to have to invest in yourself to
develop the skills to add value to the
world. If you want to try any of these
ideas, follow these specific [music]
steps. First, create your outcomebased
offer. Don't sell your time. Map to a
pain the customer already has. help them
make money or save time around an area
that they're really in pain around
because pain is a perfect way to figure
out what they're willing to pay for.
Make a promise that's specific around a
result in a very specific time frame.
That's how you create a compelling offer
and then just remove all the risks. Just
tell them what the guarantee is and then
say, "Because it's just you, [music] you
can only take so many clients, so I'm
only looking for three or five clients."
That creates urgency and it'll get them
to buy right away. And for what it's
worth, if you [music] want to make this
super easy, I can send you my exact
offer template. So, all you have to do
is copy and paste it. It'll save you
hours of tweaking and adjusting and
testing. Just DM me the [music] words
YouTube offer on Instagram or click the
link in the description below and I'll
send it over. So, once you have your
offer, just do one daily outreach.
That's a non-negotiable. If you want to
make money online, set it and forget it.
It's just a habit. So, reach out to one
potential client every day until you get
customers. But you just have to have a
clear offer. That's what this bucket
will teach you. That skill of crafting
an offer, getting somebody to understand
it, and paying you. [music] This will
get you the best chance to be successful
in this bucket. That being said, if you
already have experience [music] or you
want income that's more consistent, the
medium bucket might actually be better
choice.
Bucket number three, the medium bucket.
Essentially, the income potential is 10
to 50K per month minimum. Difficulty
level, it's medium, but multi-kill work
tied to real business outcomes makes you
money. You're not just doing task
anymore. You're solving revenue and
growth problems for businesses. And the
time frame to make real money could be 3
months, maybe worst case 12 months, but
you're setting up your future. And it's
best for people that have some skill but
want more stability and scale. When I
look at Sam on my media team, Sam didn't
ask for a step-by-step instruction to be
successful. He just framed the outcome.
He took ownership and he delivered.
Because of that, he got opportunities to
step up. That's why you've probably seen
the video of me giving him his dream
car, a Porsche GT4. It wasn't because he
was doing little tiny tasks. [music]
It's because he actually delivered the
outcome. And for me, that became vastly
more valuable. And that's what's
different about this bucket. You're no
longer just doing the skill. You're
actually tying your pay to an outcome.
The only way for your clients to make
more money is for them to focus on
solving bigger problems which mean you
come in and take the smaller [music]
problems off their plate. So what are
some examples in this category? The
first one automation agencies. This
one's the new hotness. Why? The demand
for this alone makes it a fantastic
opportunity and it makes you bulletproof
for the future. businesses are literally
drowning in opportunity to automate and
it makes them money quickly and it saves
them time at scale and it's going to
futureproof [music] you for other
companies. Next, we got LinkedIn growth
systems powered by AI. Every CEO or
leader out there, they need more reach.
They need people to know who they are.
They need people to know, like, and
trust them. And if you're the kind of
person to come in and own that outcome
of getting that attention, that
audience, that trust, [music] they will
pay you to help them grow. Next, we've
got micro SASS, near and dear to my
heart, and really AI tools for small
businesses. These are like really small,
tiny tools that help save people time.
So, you can have like a plugin, an
extension, an app for a marketplace,
[music] but the cool part is you charge
monthly for simple, clear value, and
that's how you stack revenue. Next,
we've got an AI content agency. This one
is super fun, especially if you love
content. I mean, brands are always
looking for more content that's aligned
to help them create associations [music]
to help their business. So, you use AI
to produce high volumes without
shooting. It's crazy. So, look into like
Hey Genen, 11 Labs, and other tools like
that that'll make this job easy. And for
these last two options, just take a
screenshot for all the AI tools that I
put up on screen so that you can make
this option way easier. And last, we
have highquality motion graphic [music]
designers. The more AI can do all kind
of lowquality stuff and like people are
shooting more and more content. What's
missing is somebody to understand how to
do motion graphics. This is the
separator. This is where you make
content [music] look pro. So you want to
learn After Effects plus all the AI
tools that help you make and deliver
premium assets fast. And for these last
two options, take a screenshot of all
these AI tools that will make it so much
easier for you. If you fall in love with
this bucket, here are two pro tips that
you need. One, build three to five
measurable case studies that you can
tell to other people. That way, it'll
allow you to sell to more clients fast.
So, if you're just starting off, maybe
you find people that represent your
ideal customer profile and offer to
either do it at a discount or free. I
don't love free, but let's say discount.
And in return for that discount, they
agree to let you use their project as a
case study to talk to other customers
about. Two, sell outcomebased monthly
retainers instead of one-off projects. I
still see people in today's age that are
selling their time for [music] money.
You have to disconnect from that. Don't
get stuck in it. Don't start there.
Don't get in the trap. When you can sell
outcomes, especially like monthly
retainers for a specific outcome, that
creates predictability and reoccurring
revenue in your business. And that is
the most beautiful place to get. And
that is how you make real money online.
But if you want to build something way
bigger than yourself, something that
could actually [music] change your
entire life, the hard bucket is where
it's at. Bucket number four, the hard
bucket. The income potential here could
be like a million plus a month.
Honestly, millions. The difficulty level
though is high cuz it's going to require
systems, leadership, and honestly
long-term thinking. It's hard to get
into and it may need some capital or
expertise, but you will see a massive
return. And the time frame to get to
this level, if you start from zero,
could take two to 10 years or more,
depending on your level of effort. It's
best for people who want to build
something bigger than themselves.
Essentially, an asset or even better, an
empire. [music] And the reason why is
because you're building something that
someone else might actually buy. The
people in this bucket are my kind of
people. So, let's run through some
examples. The first, [music] investing
in AI first founders. This is my world.
See, back in the day, I've been doing AI
investing for over seven years.
Companies like Flex Pay or Intercom,
etc. These are all companies I was
involved in in the early days. And
what's cool about it is that if you have
the capital and you invest in them, when
they win, you win. When you get equity
without running the company yourself,
you get a lot of time back. So, this is
a great way to create leverage and
create an empire. I've personally
invested in over a 100 companies using
this method. And starting from 2026,
this is going to get way bigger. A lot
of people are going to be able to do
this one. Next, we got software AI
products. Essentially, this is my world.
This is what I build at Martell
Ventures. We have built or partnered
with people that have launched a new AI
company every month for the last year
and a little bit. And I'm telling you,
this one has made me more money than
anything I've ever done my whole life.
The key to make it work is you got to
build tools that solve real problems in
a way that's unique. Most of the
applications that I'm working on,
honestly, the AI [music] isn't powerful
enough yet for it to work. Not only is
it a great way to generate reoccurring
revenue because it's software, but you
build some value where people will pay
you 10 [music] to 50 times more than
your topline revenue for the business.
Next is buying small businesses and
using AI to automate 30 to 50% of it.
It's so crazy how there's like these
really simple businesses that are still
stuck in the 80s. My friend Jason bought
a campground a couple years ago and all
he did was put in AI powered booking
software, management software,
maintenance software, and the thing
prints cash today, but buying a boring
business that somebody else is done with
using AI is a great way to create real
wealth. Next, we've got personal brand
or content machine for deal flow. I
break it into content and commerce.
You've seen this with Mr. Beast and
Feastables. You've seen this with Logan
Paul and Prime. You've seen [music] this
with all these content creators. But if
you can build a personal brand, build
distribution, then you have a way to
introduce customers to a product that
creates equity, that creates enterprise
value, and this is in the hard bucket
because most people are willing to stick
with it. It takes time. It takes
commitment. It takes dedication. You got
to be consistent. Most people would
rather take the easy way. That's why
it's in the hard bucket. Next, we've got
subscription communities powered by AI
curation. I've seen so many of these
online communities now where essentially
people pay every month to be part of a
group so that they have access to
knowledge and experience and the AI is
designed to answer their questions to
support them. It's faster, it's easier,
and you can build a business from it.
And last, licensing AI playbooks. This
is where most companies don't realize
their system prompts is their new IP,
their intellectual property. So, if you
have a business that has created these
playbooks that are AI powered, you can
copy paste those and sell them to other
businesses by making them passive
income. Like, just go look at all the
custom GPTs you can buy. A lot of people
are like creating innovation inside
their own business and licing it to
other companies [music] and making a ton
of money. This is a really cool one that
I think a lot of people are sleeping on.
The hard bucket is near and dear to my
heart because it's a reflection of my
life. I mean, a lot of people see me
today and they see all the success and
the accolades, but they don't know where
I started. I started as a software
programmer at 17 writing code and it
took me almost seven years to finally
find any software any traction what I
was doing and eventually at 28 I sold my
company and I became a multi-millionaire
and it's the thing that ultimately made
me financially successful but better
than anything it created the confidence
in my abilities that I could then apply
to my other companies. So don't forget
you don't get the hockey stick without
the flat first year. So, you have to
learn how to invest and reinvest and
recommmit if you ever want to be
successful. Here's [snorts] how you do
this for yourself step by step. One, tie
your strongest skill to a fast growing
industry. If you don't know what that
is, ask AI. It'll tell you. Second is
systematize your service. Don't sell
your time. Sell an outcome so that you
can build the system around delivering
that outcome and create automation so
it's systematized. Third is build a
small team slowly. Surround yourself
with killers. I believe the first 12
people that come into your business will
dictate your success. You want to be
slow on making sure they're the right
fit for what you're trying to do. And
for what it's worth, avoid adding
headcount where AI could do the job for
you. Number four, layer AI into your
operations to increase your margins. Get
rid of the cost. Get AI to build that
automation. And last, use content to
create inbound deal flow. If I would
have known when I started creating
content that not only would bring
opportunities to me, but it would bring
talent, it would bring friendships, it
would bring invites to things that you
couldn't even pay for, I would have
started a long time ago. So, no matter
what you decide to do in this bucket,
just make sure you create content around
it. None of this matters. If you fall
into the trap that destroys more
businesses than anything else, the shiny
object syndrome. Most people fail not
because they were in the wrong bucket,
but because they switch buckets every
few weeks. I got a friend, he's the same
age as me. I've watched him go from like
one idea to the other idea to the next
idea to another idea, and he hasn't
found any traction. Why? He keeps
resetting every time. Every 2 or 3
years, it's like, "Oh, that didn't work
cuz of this. I'm going to do this now."
Here's why. When you start from scratch,
you can't be wrong. If you stick long
enough with something it doesn't work,
then it can feel demoralizing. But the
real way to win is to stay in the game
long enough to win. See, winners lose
more than losers by definition of being
a winner. I know it sounds crazy, but
that's what it's going to take. So,
don't get distracted. Focus. Follow one
course until successful. Pick one of
these options out of these buckets and
execute. Just remember, you can do
anything, just not everything. So,
here's how you avoid the shiny object
syndrome. One, commit to a,000 days of
focus. Don't stop. Be consistent. Two,
document [music] the journey. Put it in
public. Build in public. It'll actually
hold you accountable because everybody's
going to be waiting to see what you're
going to post next. If you just do these
two things, it'll increase your
probability of success more than
anything else you could do. And the most
important thing is that you commit.
Don't just hear all of this and do
nothing. The separator in 2026 is the
people that show up and do. And those
are the folks that make it this far. So,
if that's you, I want a commitment. Type
commitment below. Look me in the eyes
and let me know you're one of the people
that are different. You're the one
that's not just going to do shelf help,
listen to a lot of stuff, and put it up
on a shelf, but you're actually going to
focus until you get results. And
remember, if any of you are
entrepreneurs out there and you want my
exact offer template to help you get
clients, just DM me the word YouTube
offer on Instagram or click the link
below and I'll send it right over. And
if you want to learn how to scale any
business from absolutely very beginning
to the end, click here and I'll see you
on the other